[Applaudissements]
voilà alors vous un petit bisou pas
continue mais une musique tous faim qui
s'est alors amené japonais j'ai
l'impression d'être devant une vitrine
de pâtisserie à tout va et goûter
[Applaudissements]
audrey javel
daniel qui val maggia que quelques je
trouve à midi daniel j'adore cette
émission la petite emilie n'a pu ne
m'avait bien promis trois poils de son
cul pour faire un tapis y ait tant pis
mais quand on est habillé coutu la
petite emilie la plus lookée voilà
c'était jean dutourd est en fait j'ai
envie de me rapprocher de quelqu'un et
puis sur la droite
voila voila c est quand même je sais pas
et je penche vaille est d'accord c'est
vraiment au monde s'y penche
vous dansez a pas du tout non je vis
avec ma mère dans un très vieil
appartement dans la chanson dont michel
voilà je sens qu'on a on qu'on a du
feeling même si vous ne sentez pas
encore je suis toujours un petit peu en
avance donc je compte sur vous pour me
lever au propre comme au figuré parce
que je suis pas sûr que je vais pouvoir
me relever là j'espère vous faire
craquer au moins autant que mes genoux
crack en ce moment voilà donc c'est
jean-michel voulez vous coucher avec moi
c'est ce qu'a dit
[Applaudissements]